Evet canlarım selamlar. Hemen 3.
ünitemize geçelim. Orta Çağ
medeniyetleri diyeceğiz ve biz burada ne
öğreneceğiz? En başta bugünün konusu
Orta Çağ'daki kitlesel göçler. Çok
basit. Gerçekten zorlanmayacağınız
noktalardan biridir. Orta Çağ'daki
siyasi ve askeri gelişmeler, Orta Çağ'da
ticaret yolları, Orta Çağ'da bilim,
kültür ve sanat diyeceğiz. Bunlar
bittikten sonra sen zaten artık 10.
sınıf olacaksın. Eee, bu dönemi boş
geçirmeyelim. Bu dönemi anlayarak, marif
modeli çözerek, anlamlandırarak gidelim
ki yeni sınav sisteminde neyle
karşılaşacağımız tam olarak belli değil.
En azından sınavlarımızda, yeni sınav
sisteminde zorlanmadan yolunuza, eğitim
hayatınıza devam edin. Şimdi canlarım
gerçekten de basit bir konu olduğunu
söyleyebilirim. Bir kere göç nedir?
Bununla başlayalım. Orta Çağ'da kitlesel
göçler derken göç hareketinin bir
tanımını yapmak lazım. Bir topluluğun
bulunduğu coğrafyadan belirli sebeplerle
başka bir bölgeye göç etmesine, yer
değiştirmesine biz göç etmek ya da göç
hareketi diyoruz. Burada Türklerin ana
yurdunun Orta Asya olduğunu bilmemiz
lazım. Türkistan dediğimiz, Orta Asya
dediğimiz coğrafya Türklerin tarih
boyunca anayurt olarak kabul ettiği,
devletlerini özellikle kurup yaşamlarını
idame ettirdiği yerdi. Ama Türkler
zamanla bu bölgeden başka bölgelere göç
etmek durumunda kaldı. ki buralar
arasında göç edilen yerler arasında Çin,
Hindistan şöyle renklendirelim
isterseniz. Bakın burada ne var? Çin
toprakları işte Hindistan coğrafyası.
Bakalım Orta Avrupa, Balkan toprakları,
İran coğrafyası, Mezopotamya bölgesi,
Anadolu, Türklerin göç ettiği
yaşamlarını idame ettirdikleri
yerlermiş. Biz şimdi buranın bir
haritasını görelim canlarım. Şimdi
Anadolu dediğimiz coğrafyayı hepimiz
biliyoruz. Anadolu burası. Balkanlar
dediğim zaman Evet. Balkanlar,
Yunanistan, Bulgaristan, Kosova,
Sırbistan, Bosna, Hersek, Arnavutluk
gibi bölgelerin bulunduğu yerler Balkan
coğrafyası. Orta Avrupa deyince
gerçekten geniş bir alan bizi bekliyor.
Avrupa'nın ortası. Bakalım Kafkasya
toprakları mesela aklınızda olsun. Bu
coğrafya, Orta Asya dediğimiz yer zaten
çok geniş bir alan. Türklerin anaydu,
Çin dediğimiz zaman evet Orta Asya'nın
hemen bitişiğinde ve Türklerin ebedi
mücadele ettiği devletti. hem ticaret
yolunda ipek yolu mücadelesini verdi.
Hem savaştı hem de ticaret yaptı.
Akrabalık kurdu. Ebedi bir düşmandı.
Hindistan coğrafyası dediğimiz zaman
aklımıza hemen bu bölge gelmeli.
Hindistan coğrafyası. Türkler Orta
Asya'dan Anadolu'ya gelmişler.
Balkanlara gelmişler. Orta Avrupa'ya
geçmişler. Bakıyorum İran toprakları
şurası. İran bölgesine göç etmişler.
Hindistan'a göç etmişler. Çin
topraklarına göç etmişler. Dolayısıyla
Türkler hiçbir yerde durmamışlar. Bu da
zaten onları dinamik bir toplum yapmış.
Yani yerinde durmayan, sürekli hareket
eden bir yapıda yaşamışlar. Peki
canlarım, Türkler Orta Asya'dan göç
ettiler. Bunun sebepleri nedir dersek
hemen şöyle bir inceleyelim. Bir kere
Türkler siyasi anlamda baktığımız zaman
devletlerinin genişletmek için yani
devletlerin sınırlarını genişletmek için
göç edecekler. Siyasi istikrarsızlıktan
dolayı bulundukları bölgede
barınamıyorlar. Savaşlar çıkıyor. Siyasi
güç mücadeleleri yaşanıyor. Türklerin
kendi aralarında yaptığı mücadeleler
var. Bir de dış baskılar var. İşte o
dönemde Moğollar ya da Tunguzlar ya da
Çinlilerin baskıları, farklı farklı
milletler Türklere saldırdıkça Türkler
de anayurtları ne yapmışlar? Bırakıp göç
etmek zorunda kalmışlar. ekonomik yani
iktisadi açıdan baktığımız zaman
otlakların azalması, sulakların
azalması, kuraklığın yaşanması, ekonomik
fırsatlar, başka bölgelerdeki fırsatlar
aklımızı çelmiş ve toprakların
verimsizliği. Orta Asya gerçekten de
baktığımız zaman çok yüksek engebeli,
dağlık bir bölge. Verimsiz bir bölge.
Yani verimli olan yer sayısı çok az
gerçekten. O yüzden çok daha cazip
coğrafyalar varmış ve Türkler bu yüzden
Orta Asya'yı bırakıp Ana'tten çıkıp
başka bölgelere gitmişler. Bunda tabii
ki sosyal anlamda nüfusun çok artması da
etkili olmuş. Zaten otlaklar, sulak
alanlar yetersiz. Kuraklık var. Bir de
nüfus çok olunca ne olur? İnsanlar zor
duruma düşer. Coğrafi olarak bakacaksak,
evet, coğrafi koşullar Orta Asya'da
gerçekten elverişsizdi. Ormanlık
alanlar, bataklık alanlar yaşam alanını
daraltıyordu. İklim koşulları zaten
verimli değildi. Yaşamaya çok müsait
değildi. Düşünsenize yazın + 50 derece,
kışın -50 dereceyi gören sıcaklık
farkları oluyor Orta Asya'da.
Dolayısıyla Anadolu coğrafyasıyla
kıyasladığın zaman hangisi daha
yaşanabilir? Tabii ki Anadolu
coğrafyası. Böyle düşünebilirsiniz.
Türklerin konar göçer yaşamasında yani
belirli bölgelerde birkaç ayda bir yer
değiştirmesinde ya da ana yurtlarını
bırakıp başka bölgelere göç etmelerinde
özellikle atın ve tekerleğin
kullanılması çok önem arz ediyor. Çünkü
Türklerin göç hareketlerini ya da konar
göçer yaşamalarını kolaylaştıran bir
unsur olmuş. Orta Asya dediğimiz
coğrafya yani Türklerin ana yurdunda
Türkistan'da kimler yaşıyordu? Kimler
nereye gitti? Bir bakalım. Mesela
Sibirler dediğimiz evet Rusya'nın güney
kısmında yaşıyormuş Türkler zamanında ve
orada Sibir dediğimiz ya da Sabarlar
dediğimiz devleti kurmuşlar. Hazarlar
dediğimiz zaman aklımıza Museviliği
benimseyen ilk Türk devleti geliyordu.
Hazarlarda Karadeniz'in kuzey
bölgelerinde Kafkas dağlarının kuzey
coğrafyasında kurulmuş Musevili'yi
benimsemiş bir devletti. Peçenekler,
kumanlar, uzlar. Bunlar özellikle
ücretli askerlik yapmalarıyla bilinen
Türk devletleriydi. Hazarların kuzey
topraklarında Doğu Avrupa coğrafyasına
doğru yayılan geniş alanlara
yayılmışlar. Oğuzlar en kalabalık Türk
boyudur. Oğuzlar 10-11. yüzyıllarda
Orhun bölgesinden Seyhun Nehri
kenarlarına, Maverraün Nehir üzerinden
İran'a ve Anadolu'ya göç etmişler.
Canlarım, Oğuzlar bildiğimiz en önemli
Türk devletlerinin kurucu boyudur. En
kalabalık Türk boyu olarak bilinir.
Mesela Türkiye Selçuklu, Büyük Selçuklu,
Osmanlı, Akkoyunlu Devleti, Karakoyunlu
Devleti gibi devletler Oğuzlardan
kurulmuştur. Buna özellikle dikkat edin.
Mesela Büyük Selçuklu Oğuzların Kınık
boyundan, Osmanlı Devleti ise Oğuzların
kayı boyundan gelmekte. E bunu
bilmemizde fayda var. Hunlar dersem
evet. Çin'e göç eden bazı Türk boyları
kuzey Çin'de Hun ve Tabgaç ya da Tabgıç
dediğimiz devletin kurulmasını
sağlamışlar. Akunlar dediğimiz devlet
günümüz Hindistan Afganistan
coğrafyasına doğru yayılmış bir
devlettir. Eftalitler olarak da
biliniyor. Uygurlar burada çok önemli.
Uygurlar 840'ı takip eden yıllarda yani
9. yüzyılda Orhun Nehri çevresinden
Türkistan'a göç etmişler. Bulgarlar
Karadeniz'in kuzeyinden Balkanlara,
Volga Nehri kıyılarına göç etmişler. 9.
yüzyılda Bulgar devleti kurmuşlar. Bu
Bulgarlarda önemli bir devlet. Hatta bir
süre sonra ikiye ayrılmışlar. Tuna
Bulgarları ve İdil Bulgarları olmak
üzere iki şekilde varlıklarını devam
ettirmişler. Yan canlarım bu haritada
neyi gördünüz siz? Aslında kimin nerede
yaşadığı ve nereye göç ettiği şeklinde
bir harita değerlendirmesi yaptık. Şimdi
Türk göçlerinin sonuçları Türklerin ana
yurdunu bırakıp da başka bölgelere göç
etmesinin sonucunda ne olur? Türk
kültürü geniş bir coğrafyaya yayılmış
olur. Farklı coğrafyalarda yeni yeni
Türk devletleri kurulur. Türk kültürü
yayılır. Türk tarihini bir bütün halinde
incelemek zorlaşır. Düşünsene Orta
Asya'da bir kazı yapıyorsun. Bu kazı
belirli bir süreye devam ettiriyor. Bir
bakıyorsun bilgiler kesiliyor. Bir
bakıyorsun o bölgede yaşayan Türkler
başka bir bölgeye göç etmişler.
Dolayısıyla tarihi araştırmak
zorlaşacaktır. Mesela şöyle düşün.
Çin'in tarihini mi araştırmak daha
zordur? Türklerin tarihini mi araştırmak
daha zordur? Tabii ki Türkler çünkü
konar göçer yaşamışlar. Sürekli göç
etmişler. Bu da işi zorlaştırmış. Tabii
ki Türkler başka bölgelere göç ettikçe
kültürlerinde de değişimler olacak.
Mesela Balkanlara, Avrupa'ya göç eden
Türklerde Hristiyanlık yayılacak ve
askeri anlamda özellikle gittiğimiz
bölgelerde başka medeniyetleri
etkileyeceğiz. Yani göçler sonucunda
kültürel etkileşim yaşanacak. Buna da
dikkat edersiniz. Kavimler göçü
öncesinde Asya ve Avrupa'nın siyasi
durumu. Arkadaşlar biraz sonra çok
önemli bir değerlendirme yapacağız.
Kavimler göçünü anlatacağız. Peki
kavimler göçü 375 yılında yaşanıyor.
Onun öncesinde nasıl bir durum vardı?
Orta Asya'da bir kere Asya Hunları diye
bir devlet vardı. Türk tarihinde bilinen
ilk devlet olarak geçiyor ve Asya
Hunları bir süre sonra zayıflıyor
canlarım. Parçalanıyor ve Çin
baskısından dolayı bu kavimler göçünü
başlatan devlet aslında Hunlar oluyor.
Buna dikkat edersiniz. Kavimler göçünden
önce Çin Asya'nın doğusunda güçlü bir
devlet olarak zaten yüzlerce yıl
varlığını devam ettirmişti. Hunlarla
mücadele halindelerdi. Özellikle İpek
Yolu güzergahında Çinlilerle Hunlar
sürekli savaşıyorlar. Ona dikkat
edersiniz. Sasaniler kendilerini
Persilerin, İran topraklarındaki Pers
medeniyetinin varisi olarak gören güçlü
bir devlet. Roma medeniyetiyle özellikle
uzun yıllar süren savaşları aslında
Türklerin de işine gelmiştir. Bu açıdan
değerlendirmek lazım. Avrupa'ya baktığım
zaman zaten Roma İmparatorluğu var.
kavimler göçünden önce merkeziyetçi bir
devlet olarak varlığını sürdürüyordu.
Ama kavimler göçü sonucunda bu Roma
İmparatorluğu ne yapacak? 395 yılında
ikiye ayrılacak. Doğu Roma ve Batı Roma
olmak üzere yeni yeni Roma devletleri
ortaya çıkacak. Germen kavimlere
baktığımız zaman Ostrogotlar,
Vizigotlar, Franklar, Vandallar, Süev,
Burgont gibi çeşitli Germen kabileleri
vardı. İşte bu kavimler göçü esnasında
bunlar yer değiştirince Roma
İmparatorluğu istilahaya uğradı. Avrupa
istilah uğradı ve bu germen kavimler
günümüzdeki Avrupa milletlerinin aslında
temelini oluşturmuş oldu. Şimdi hemen
kavimler Güçü olayını bir tanımlayalım,
anlayalım. Arkadaşlar şöyle düşünün.
Asya Hun Devleti güçlü bir devletti.
Mete Han zamanında en güçlü dönemini
yaşadı. Daha sonra Mete öldükten sonra
zaten iç karışıklıklar patlak verdi. Çin
etkisi ülkede görülmeye başlandı ve en
sonunda kuzey ve güney olmak üzere
Hunlar ikiye ayrıldı. Burada kuzeyde
bulunan Hunlar Çin baskısına,
saldırılarına dayanamadı. Balamir
öncülüğünde batıya doğru göç etmeye
başladı. Batıya doğru göç ederken de
önüne bazı barbar kavimler çıktı. Mesela
Germenler, Ostrogotlar, Vizigotlar gibi
savaşçı, barbar kavimler Hunların önüne
çıkınca Hunlar bunları yenerek bunların
yer değiştirmesine, batıya doğru hareket
etmesine sebep oldu. İşte biz Hunlar
öncülüğünde başlayan Germen savaşçı
kavimlerin batıya doğru göç etmesiyle
sonuçlanan bu göç hareketine kavimler
göçü diyoruz. Bu kavimler göçünün
yaşanması dünya tarihinde gerçekten
dönüm noktalarından biridir. Neden
dolayı biliyor musunuz? Çünkü kavimler
göçü bazı tarihçilerin değerlendirmesine
göre ilk çağın sona ermesi, orta çağın
başlaması olarak kabul ediliyor. Bazı
tarihçiler de ilk çağın sona ermesi,
Orta Çağ'ın başlamasını Batı Roma
İmparatorluğu'nun yıkılması olarak
belirliyor. Bu şekilde kabul ediyor.
Demek ki bir görüşe göre 375 kavimler
göçü, bir görüşe göre 476 Batı
Romanın'ın yıkılması yeni bir çağın
başlangıcı olarak değerlendirilmiş.
Şimdi kavimler göçünü haritadan bir
değerlendirelim. Hunlar doğudan Çin'in
yanından bu baskıya dayanamayıp batıya
doğru göç etmişler. Kim öncülüğünde?
Balamir öncülüğünde. Önüne çıkan Alan,
Ostrogot, Vizigot gibi bazı barbar
kavimleri batıya doğru hareket
ettirmişler ve Roma İmparatorluğu'nun
sınırlarında bu barbar kavimler
birikmiş, birikmiş. Tabii doğudan
Türkler geliyor. Batıda da Roma
İmparatorluğu var. Bunlar arada
kalmışlar. Avrupa sınırlarına
dayanmışlar ve Avrupa'ya en son istila
etmişler. Bu kavimler göçü sonucunda da
ne olmuş? Roma İmparatorluğu
parçalanmış. Bu bizim için önemli. Şimdi
birer birer değerlendirelim. Kavimler
göçü yaşanırsa ne olur? Sonucunda neler
yaşanır? Bakın kavimler göçü Orta Çağ
Avrupa'sı siyasi, sosyal, kültürel
yapısını belirleyen önemli bir dönüm
noktası olmuş. Germen kabileleri
fethettikleri topraklarda kendi
krallıklarını, yönetimlerini kurmuşlar.
Avrupa'yı islah edip Avrupa'daki tüm
siyasi düzeni ve ekonomik verileri
değiştirmişler. Avrupa'da uzun süren iç
karışıklıklar, çatışmalar, kaos ortamı
yaşanmış. Kavimler göçüyle iç
karışıklıkların bitmediği Roma
İmparatorluğu en sonunda 395 yılında
ikiye ayrılmış. Doğu Roma yani Bizans
dediğimiz devlet ve Batı Roma olmak
üzere iki Roma ortaya çıkmış. Batı Roma
dediğimiz devlet bir süre sonra
Süevlerin, Vandalların baskısı sonucunda
476 yılında yıkılıp gidiyor. Ama Doğu
Roma dediğimiz devlet 1453 yılına Mehmet
Fatih Sultan Mehmet dönemine kadar
varlığını devam ettiriyor. Peki Roma
İmparatorluğu parçalanırsa özellikle
Batı Roma dediğimiz devlet yıkılırsa ne
olur? Orta Çağ Avrupa'sında iktidar
boşluğu olur. Yani o merkeziyetçi
yönetim ortadan kalktıktan sonra bu
barbar kavimler yönetimlerini kurmak,
güçlenmek için çatışma ortamına
girdiler. Bu da o Avrupa'daki o dengeyi,
düzeni, istikrarı ne yaptı? Bozdu. Küçük
küçük krallıklar dediğimiz bu toprağa
dayalı feodal yönetim anlayışı ortaya
çıktı. Avrupa'da feodalizmin
yaşanmasında demek ki kavimler göçünün
bariz bir etkisi var. Bunun dışında
skolastik düşünce gelişti. Yani
Papa'nın, kilisenin, din adamının
dediğinin olduğu, dini görüşlerin
sorgulanamadığı, Papa'nın, kilisenin
eleştirilmediği, mutlak bir şekilde
gücün din adamlarına geçtiği bir dönem
yaşanacak. Biz bu döneme skolastik
düşünce diyeceğiz. Bilimin, sanatın,
teknik anlamdaki gelişmelerin
yaşanmadığı, tamamen dini görüşün hayata
etki ettiği bir dönem. Bu da Avrupa'nın
açıkçası gerilemesinde, kalkınamamasında
etkili olan bir sistemdir. Merkeziyetçi
devlet olan Roma İmparatorluğu'nun
parçalanmasıyla tabii ki bir süre sonra
Roma kültürü de Avrupa'da etkisini
kaybetti. Avrupa'da Türk kültürü
yayıldı. Avrupa'da ilk Türk devleti olan
Avrupa Hun Devleti kuruldu canlarım.
Kavimler göçü sonrasında Avrupa
milletlerinin temeli atılmış oldu. Çünkü
Roma İmparatorluğu parçalandı. Germen
kavimler Avrupa'da yaşayan kavimlerle
akrabalık kurdu, evlendiler, çocukları
oldu. Yeni bir millet anlayışı ortaya
çıktı. Tabii ki bu süreç kaos, gözyaşı,
kan, savaşlar, çatışmalar şeklinde
geçti. Ve bu her barbar kavim belirli
bir bölgeye geçip orada hakimiyet alanı
kurdular. Mesela baktığımız zaman
İngiltere topraklarında Angılllar ve
Saksonlar ortaya çıktı. o bölgeyi ele
geçirdi. Fransa ve Galya topraklarında
Franklar, Güney Fransa bölgesinde
Burgontlar, İspanya topraklarında
Sülevler, İspanya ve Afrika bölgesinde
Vandallılar hakim oldu. İtalya ve
İspanya coğrafyasındaysa Ostrogotlar ve
vizigotlar hakimiyet kurdu bu bölgede
yaşadılar. Gelelim çok önemsediğimiz bir
kavrama. Feodal sistem. Burayı ince ince
analiz edeceğiz. Lütfen burayı anlamadan
geçmeyin. Çünkü göçleri, kitlesel
göçleri anlarsınız. Basit ama feodal
sistemi anlamak zorundasınız. Çünkü bu
yeni sistemde, yeni sınav sisteminde de
karşımıza mutlaka gelecek bir kavram.
Şimdi canlarım, Roma İmparatorluğu'nun
yıkılmasıyla Avrupa'da ortaya çıkan
siyasi boşlukta barbar kavimler, feodal
beyler ve kilise ne yapıyor? Bu boşluğu
dolduruyor. Feodalizmin sözcük anlamına
baktığımız zaman toprağa dayalı sistem.
En güzel ifade eden kavram şu. Şuraya
dikkat edin. Feodalite toprağın ve
toprak üzerindeki egemenliğin
parçalandığı üretim ve yönetim
sistemidir. Bakın bir hem ekonomik
sistemdir, toprağa dayalı bir sistemdir
hem de bu toprağa dayalı sistemde
güçlenen birilerinin olmasıyla siyasi
bir yöntem olarak yüzyıllar boyunca
Avrupa'da görülmüştür bu sistem. Bir
kere feodal düzenin ortaya çıkabilmesi
için feodal beyler dediğimiz o toprak
sahibi güçlü insanların ortaya çıkıp da
halkı sömürebilmesi, kullanabilmesi için
merkeziyetçi bir yönetimin olmaması
gerekiyor. Ve Roma İmparatorluğu'nun
parçalanması işte bu merkeziyetçi
yönetim boşluğunu ortaya çıkarıyor ve
feodal düzen ortaya çıkıyor. Bu feodal
düzende krallar yine en üst katmanda ama
krallara mutlak bir şekilde
bağlılıklarını bildirilmiş toprak
beyleri var. Senyör dediğimiz toprak
zenginleri, toprak beyleri krala mutlak
itaatle kendi askerleri, şövalyeleri,
kendi kurdukları düzenle ne yapıyorlar?
Varlıklarını Avrupa'da devam
ettiriyorlar. Bunlar böyle şatolarda
yaşıyorlar. Şatolarda kendilerine ait
bir düzen kuruyorlar. Kendi askerleri
var. Krala bağlı olarak varlıklarını
devam ettiriyorlar. Şuraya dikkat edin.
Feodalitede siyasi yönetim
organizasyonunun en üst tepesinde mutlak
egemenliğe sahip olmayan yetkileri
sınırlı bir kral var. Başta kral var.
Ama krallar eskisi gibi güçlü değil.
Çünkü bu gücünü feodal beylerle
paylaşmak zorunda kalıyor. Ama sonuçta
en üstte kim varmış? Kral varmış. Kralın
altında genel olarak senyör adıyla
anılan kontlar, dükler dediğimiz siyasi
güçler var. Bunlar kendi aralarında
böyle bir hiyerarşi oluşturmuşlar. Demek
ki bu hiyerarşinin üstünde senyor
dediğimiz gruplar varmış. Feodal
toplumun en alt katmanındaysa köylüler
varmış. Bunların hakları sınırlı.
Denileni yaparlar. Karınlarını doyurup
yaşarlar. Nüfusun az olması ve üretimin
yeterli gelmemesi yoksulluğun aşırı bir
şekilde yükselmesine sebep olmuş. Bu
toplumsal yapı içerisinde yalnız iki
sınıf soylular ve ruhbanlar yani din
adamı grubu hem maddi hem de manevi
anlamda toplumun önde gelenleri
olmuşlar. Halkı sömürmüşler. Güçlerine
güç katmışlar. Zenginleşmişler. Demek ki
canlarım bu Orta Çağ Avrupa'sındaki
merkeziyetçi yönetimin kaybolmasıyla din
adamları bunun ekmeğini yemiş. Senyörler
bunun ekmeğini yemiş ve kilise özellikle
Katolik kilisesi çok güç kazanmış ve
halkı sömürmüş. Skolastik düşünce
denilen bilimin, sanatın, tekniğin
gelişmediği dönemde din adamları kendi
düzenlerini kurmuşlar. Bak hem dini
açıdan hem de siyasi açıdan bir güç
unsuru var. Din adamları var, senyörler
var, krallar var. Bu şekilde halkı
sömürmüşler. Gelelim Avrupa Hun
devletine arkadaşlar. Avrupa Hunları
kavimler göçüyle kurulan bir devlettir.
Avrupa'da kurulan ilk Türk devletidir.
Kurucusu da zaten Balamird'dir. Avrupa
unları günümüz Macaristan topraklarında
Orta Avrupa'da hakimiyet kurmuş. Elbe
nehri kadar yani göstereyim canlarım.
Elbe nehri dediğim yer neresi biliyor
musunuz? Bakın şöyle düşünün. Burası
Anadolu coğrafyası. Şurası Balkanlar. Şu
bölgede kuruluyor Avrupa Hunları ama şu
bölgelere kadar sınırlarını
genişletiyor. Yani Avrupa'nın büyük
oranda ele geçirildiğini düşün. Avrupa
Hunları tarafından Avrupa Hunlarında
Balamir'den sonra Uld diye bir lider
geliyor. Hunların dış politikasını Uld
oluşturuyor. Bu dönemde Doğu Roma
İmparatorluğu yani Bizans baskı altında
tutuluyor. Batı Roma'yla dostluk
kuruluyor. Daha sonra Rua diye bir
hükümdar geliyor. Bu dönemde Roma
entrikaları siyaseti etkisiz hale
getirmek için Balkan seferine çıkıyor ve
Doğu Roma'yı vergiye bağlıyor. Daha
sonra Atilla gelecek canlarım. Attila
devleti en güçlü dönemini yaşatıyor.
Unutmayın Atilla Avrupa humlarında en
güçlü dönemdir ve Avrupalıların en çok
korktuğu Türk hükümdarlarından biridir.
Atilla tanrının kırbacı, cesur
kavimlerinin efendisi olarak geçiyor.
Almanların yani Burgontların
Nibelüngungen destanında Etzel olarak
tanımlanan bir Türk hükümdarıdır. Atilla
aynı Rua gibi Doğu Roma'yı vergiye
bağlamış ve Margos Anatolios
anlaşmalarıyla Doğu Roma'ya üstünlüğünü
kabul ettirmiş bir liderdir. Bu
anlaşmalar önemli. Margos ve Anatolios
anlaşmaları deyince aklımıza Avrupa
Hunları ve Atilla gelmeli. Ne yapmış
Atilla? Balkan seferine çıkmış. Doğu
Roma'yı vergiye bağlamış. Sonra Galya
seferi düzenleyerek Batı Roma'nın
başkenti Roma topraklarını kuşatmış.
Sonra Papa Katoliklerin dini lideri.
Papa devreye girmiş ve kendini
affetmesini, Hristiyanları affetmesini
istemiş. Bu doğrultuda Atilla
seferlerden vazgeçmiş. Daha sonra zaten
öldürülmüş gitmiş. Atilla öldükten sonra
bir daha Avrupa'ı düzen tutmayacak.
Dengesini kaybedecek ve parçalanıp
gidecek. Unutmayacaksın tanrının kırbacı
olarak bilinen lider Nibelüngungen
destanında etzel olarak geçen Türk
hükümdarı kimmiş dersem Atilla
diyorsunuz. Bu önemli bizim için. Bakın
kavimler göçü sonucunda Avrupa unlarının
kurulduğu bölge burası. Batı Roma dedik,
Doğu Roma dedik. İran topraklarında da
Sasaniler var. Ve bu Cermen kavimler ne
yapmışlar? Kendi devletlerini,
yönetimlerini kurmuşlar. Franklar,
Vizigot Krallığı, Suev Krallığı gibi,
Vandallar gibi bir sürü yapılanma ortaya
çıkmış canlarım. Şimdi etkinliklerimize
bakalım. Bakın sorumuz şöyle. Birinci
etkinlikte kavimler göçü ile ilgili bu
görseldeki domino etkisiyle anlatılmak
istenen nedir? E hemen söyleyelim
bakalım. Şöyle bir Hunlar bu işi
başlatmışlar. Diğer kavimleri
etkilemişler. Bu kavimler Hun
baskısından Türklerden kaçmışlar.
Birbirlerine ne yapmışlar? Hareket
ettirmişler. Baskı oluşturmuşlar. Bu iş
kimde patlamış? Roma topraklarında. O
yüzden canlarım kavimler göçü
topluluklarının birbirini etkileyerek
hareket etmesine sebep olmuş. Hunlar
göçü başlatmış ve birçok topluluk yer
değiştirmiş, göç etmek zorunda kalmış.
Bu da Roma'nın parçalanmasıyla
sonuçlanmıştır. Bu etkinlikte bunu
yazabiliriz. İkinci etkinliğe bakalım.
Aşağıdaki soruları metne göre
cevaplayalım. Geçmişten günümüze göç
olgusu. Göç hareketleri ile birlikte
yeni coğrafyalar keşfedilmiş, yeni
devletler kurulmuş ve yeni uluslar
oluşmuştur. İnsanlığın gelişmesiyle
birlikte göçüde aynı oranda gelişen bir
yapıya dönüşmüştür. Küreselleşmenin
etkisi ve teknolojideki gelişmelerle
zaman ve mekan kavramlarının gittikçe
önemsizleştiği dünyamızda göç eylemiyle
sıkça karşılaşılır olmuştur. Geçmişten
bu yana göçler büyük oranda ekonomik
sebeplerden kaynaklanmakta. Günümüzde
ekonomik sıkıntılar, işsizlik ve düşük
ücretlerin olduğu yerler göç verirken
cazip iş imkanları ve yüksek ücretlerin
olduğu yerler göç almaktadır. Modern
dünyanın sunduğu kolaylıklar ve gelişen
teknoloji sayesinde her türlü imkandan
yararlanmak isteyen bireyler göç etmeye
daha meyilli hale gelmişler. Tamamdır.
Hemen bakalım. Şimdi diyor ki parçayla
ilişki kuracağız. Göçlerin yapılmasında
daha çok hangi alandaki sebepler etkili
olmuştur? Canlılarım burada ekonomik
verilerden, ekonomik alandaki durumdan
bahsediyor. Göçlerin siyasi etkileri
hakkında neler söyleyebiliriz? Yeni
devletlerin kurulmasına ve sınırların
değişiklik yaşamasına sebep olmuştur.
Bunu söyleyebiliriz. Modern dünya
şartları göçleri nasıl etkilemiştir
diyorsam küreselleşme ve teknoloji
alanındaki yaşanan gelişmeler göçleri
kolaylaştırmıştır. Günümüz dünyasında da
zaten bakın insanlar Afganistan'dan,
Pakistan'dan, İran'dan, Filistin'den ya
da işte Venezuela'dan bir anda kalkıp
göç hareketine girişebiliyor. Toplu
olarak ya da bireysel olarak eskisi gibi
göçler zor değil. Her geçen gün daha da
kolaylaşıyor. Devletlere başvurular
yapılıyor. O göçler, bireysel göçler ne
yapılabiliyor? kabul edilebiliyor. 3üncü
etkinlikte de ne varmış canlarım?
Aşağıdaki görselde verilen göçlerin
nedenlerinin başına hangi alanla ilgili
olduğunu yazalım bakalım. Nüfus artışı,
iç karışıklıklar ve toplum arasında
yaşanan çatışmalar. Bunlar sosyal
anlamda göç sebebidir. Siyasi anlamda
göçlerin sebeplerine baktığımız zaman
savaşlar, yönetim baskısı, idari
baskılar, sınır istilaları, sınırların
değişikliğe uğraması, savaşlar. Bunlar
ne yapıyor? siyasi anlamda toplumların,
insanların yer değiştirmesine, göç
etmesine sebep oluyor. Günümüzde de
zaten değil mi? Savaşlar insanların
sürekli olarak göç etmesinde etkili bir
gelişme. Ekonomik açıdan baktığım zaman
işsizliğin olması, geçim sıkıntısının
baş göstermesi, tarım ve hayvancılık
için elverişsiz ortamlar göçlere sebep
olmuş. Coğrafi açıdan baktığımız zaman
kuraklık, iklim şartları ve doğal
afetler, depremler, seller insanların
göç etmesine kolaylaştırıcı bir etkide
bulunmuş canlarım. Bir dahaki dersimizde
Orta Çağ medeniyetlerinde Orta Çağ'daki
siyasi ve askeri gelişmelere geçeceğiz.
Videodan çıkmadan önce videoyu
beğenirseniz, yorumlara destek atarsanız
sevinirim. Çalışmaya güzelce devam edin.
Sınavınızdan önce hemen bir genel tekrar
videonuz gelecek. Biliyorsunuz yazılı
provaları hazırlayacağız. O yüzden
kanala abone olup bildirim zilini açmayı
ihmal etmeyin. İyi çalışmalar. Kendinize
iyi bakın.